[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
débrief des questions au gouvernement
c'était un peu le baptême du feu
aujourd'hui nouveau gouvernement
nouveau premier ministre également jean
castex qui était saluée par le président
de l'assemblée richard ferrand jean
castex qui a aussi été ovationné par sa
propre majorité avant même de prendre la
parole et quand il s'est exprimé
c'était tout simplement pour fixer le
cap de son équipe gouvernementale
j'ai l'honneur de diriger ce
gouvernement qui sera un gouvernement de
combat qui sera un gouvernement
tourné vers l'efficacité qui sera un
gouvernement de dialogue qui sera un
gouvernement des territoires
parce que surtout ce sera un gage
d'efficacité pour lutter contre la crise
nous devrons être unis nous allons
engager un plan de relance ambitieux et
je m'emploierai personnellement à
veiller aux résultats et à l'efficacité
de notre action au service de la france
autre personnalité que tout le monde
attendait aujourd'hui eric
dupond-moretti ancien avocat désormais
garde des sceaux star des prétoires
habitué à être écoutée dans un silence
de cathédrale et bien eric dupond
moretti a été chahuté cet après-midi
bousculer interrompu à chaque début de
phrase
pas facile pour lui dans ce contexte de
se faire entendre pourriez vous nous
éclairer
vous ne deviez jamais occupé ce fauteuil
et vous êtes là vous ne deviez jamais
avalé de couleuvres et vous avez retiré
votre plainte pour cette atteinte
inadmissible à votre vie privée et au
secret professionnel
alors monsieur le ministre vos actions
futures seront elles en adéquation avec
vos déclarations passées ou pas quand on
est avocat pénaliste libre on n'a pas la
même parole que quand on représente
l'état ça n'échappe à personne
avez vous toujours dit la même chose
c'est vrai qu'à un moment j'ai dit que
je n'accepterais pas cette tâche
y avoir une dizaine ou une quinzaine
d'années on va mettre un terme définitif
non je vous en prie le sait déjà c'est
déjà compliqué pour moi c'est là c'est
une première mais
au parent donnez moi on ne juge
on ne les messieurs le député je
voudrais vous répondre complètement
on ne juge pas des hommes sur des a
priori me semble-t-il
vous me jugerez sur ce que j'ai fait
quand je leur ai fait et pardonnez moi
pardonnez moi vous je vais vous dire
quelque chose quand on est haut quand on
est au café du commerce on ne s'exprime
pas l'or comme quand on est avocat
quand on est avocat on ne s'exprime pas
comme quand on est ministre ça c'est
pour la forme
moi au 15 mai au café du commerce je ne
porte pas de cravate à l'assemblée jean
mais une voie là on peut tous travailler
ensemble ou à la marine
voilà ce qu'il fallait retenir de cette
séance de questions au gouvernement on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau débrief
[Musique]